in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Bob and
Elizabeth are here hey guys how are you
hey
welcome welcome where are you guys live
Charleston West Virginia Charleston West
Virginia very nice very cool well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes I love it how much have you
paid off
paid off a hundred and fourteen thousand
dollars Wow how long did that take
thirty long months days and your range
of income during that time we started at
ninety eight thousand and ended about
one thirty four way to go big raise in
30 months so what do you guys do for a
living I'm pharmaceutical sales rep
mm-hmm and I'm a teacher very cool so
what'd you do to make this income go up
this dramatically in that period of time
we took on any extra job
what's the wackiest extra job you did
you know mystery shoppings really a
thing yeah I thought that was like a
scam no it really is a thing yeah and
you can make like $1,700 in the year
doing it so yeah there you go okay
that's wacky I like it that's good very
cool
good job fun so what kind of debt was
this man I'll tell you what
I listened Dave and people will come and
do their stories and and they say I paid
off a hundred thousand dollars and it's
like their house and that's it and it's
great I'm glad for those people it's
amazing but I'm like how boring right no
I want stories a bunch of warts that's
ours it's it's got everything we got we
got gosh we got eight credit cards a
store credit card we had Sallie Mae loan
we had a car payment we owed the IRS
yeah we have we had a little bit of
everything so Wow what was the one debt
that when you paid it off you went I
hate you people I'm so glad you're gone
the state tax department the state a
state of West Virginia is worse than the
KGB I mean they're worse than the IRS
yeah yeah for sure that was very
exciting so how did you end up owing the
IRS and the state so let somebody go
back we
I own my own business before this for
about ten years
okay and davia I was too kind of to kind
of tell you short I've got to go to
practice in this you know for this week
to tell this story so all three people
this this week and I just want you to
know the three people I've told to were
pretty much strangers and they all went
out and bought Total Money Makeover this
week I'm just saying that we might sell
eight to ten million books didn't happen
it could happen all right
you have the floor moment gosh I guess
where this kind of starts is in 2005
maybe I I own my own business and it was
a direct sales business but a lot of
multi-level marketing in there as well
and I was one of these people that was
driving a you know a BMW with a single
you make it yeah yeah fake it to make it
which I found out later Dave is what
Texans call big hat no cattle movie but
at the time I called it fake it to you
make it and so we were selling this
product in people's homes and people
give referrals and this kind of stuff
and and we ran into a group of people
that we're having a hard time selling to
and we sold very well but the product
that we sold was pretty expensive and
you financed it most the time by 80% the
people that purchased financed and what
happened is this group of people we
couldn't penetrate these were Dave
Ramsey people like that's it I'm going
in and seeing what to do is I'm gonna
cry no yeah and David couldn't crack on
they don't go for same as cash they
don't care you know they didn't matter
to those people so what happened is I
bought your book just for research I did
you bug the objection
so it's awesome yeah I go down I get the
book at the bookstore and I use my
Discover card to buy it of course and
after I but I buy the book I research
and find out that the these people I
kind of use it to manipulate him and I
recruit him into my business and I say
do you believe all of what Dave Ramsey
says were just part of it because he
says get another job so I've got a
perfect opportunity for you and I would
recruit them now gets worse days these
people are horrible salespeople sorry
because they won't sell if you've got a
financing and I didn't have any luck
there at all but because of that we went
ahead and we thought like a lot of
people that do this this is pretty good
stuff no we're gonna do a version of it
there you go
so you know how well versions of this
program work out you can go and tell
them there are versions they make you
angry or what happened 30 months ago
where you decided okay we're all in we
will fell off yeah we moved and we went
to white switch jobs and start a new
career we moved to Charleston and we
joined a church we joined River Ridge
Church in Charleston and there was
Financial Peace University staring you
in the face
there's can't get away from this guy no
we sold our house and we sold all her
stuff we were like we're gonna just pay
off debt with this but we still had tons
of debt we still were just couldn't do
it can do it and then we kept trying we
kept trying and then we went to this
class and when we went to the class what
Oh so we really have to make a budget
like not just part of a budget but just
like so what's the budget happened and
then we said we paid up I think our
first credit card was like $300 we paid
it off and it was like yeah we did it
you know and then we put that towards
the next one and then the next one and
then you just spelled it rolling you
just felt it rolling
so now you're one of those dadgum Dave
Ramsey people so you paid off all of
this stuff in 30 months I mean you've
really been after it now I mean you
really you did the beans and rice and
everything yeah I mean you've been
living on nothing oh yeah these numbers
you've been living on nothing yeah okay
so the most aggravating part of this
whole thing was living in a tiny tiny
apartment and just oh I mean just the
four of us from a tiny apartment my
daughter the saddest part was we had to
get rid of the cat oh yeah I know so
that's like been her heartbreak but as
we've kind of been able to we've kind of
moved from the smaller apartment to a
bigger apartment to the bigger apartment
and so I mean our next goal obviously is
to buy the house but yeah Wow I mean
just that was the most aggravating part
was just being so cramped
good news is there's lots of cats in
West Virginia this is great you're
amazing that's fun and you're real
people and you really did this stuff
how's it feel now unbelievable I mean
it's this like losing a hundred pounds I
mean it's it's great how much did you
all fight through this process I can
tell you so in your in your you know in
the box you get the financial piece you
get a chart and I love the chart I
thought man that's so great I got a goal
I put it up and and and and start
running she came in and ripped it off
the wall I fixed that and instead I put
a number on the fridge and I put the
chart in the closet yeah Hebrews 12:11
and had the verse and then she came in
she said well you know I'm not gonna rip
that down now yeah you can't rip the
Bible down yeah that's not that's like
God will strike you yeah you guys are
fun all right your kids name and ages
this is Riley and she is 10 and this is
will and he is 9 all right very cool
Riley and will Elizabeth and Bob
Charleston West Virginia
and $14,000 paid off in 30 months great
story
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream 3
I love it you guys are awesome that is
something I would do go by the bike go
by the guys book so I could beat the
objection and close the sale I love that
absolutely fabulous and then you never
know what's gonna happen oh man that's
fun this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
and so you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind